es una vista familiar en el cielo del
sur de israel una descarga de misiles
llegan desde gaza la mayoría
interceptados antes de que lleguen al
suelo como a quien telaviv la noche del
martes
más de 60 misiles disparados hacia tel
aviv se interceptaron con la cúpula de
hierro en la cúpula de hierro es el
único sistema de emisión dual en el
mundo que proporciona una efectiva
solución de defensa a los misiles vi en
models desarrollado por empresas de
israelíes con apoyo de eeuu la cúpula de
hierro está específicamente designada
para contrarrestar misiles de corto
alcance como los que llegan desde gaza
tiene un 90% de éxito y es relativamente
barato usando radares y programas de
análisis solo intercepta misiles que son
una amenaza
pero solo hacen falta unos centenares de
cohetes domésticos para aterrorizar a la
gente ashkelón es una de las ciudades
donde no se pudieron evitar las muertes
fue uno de los 300 proyectos disparados
desde gaza israel afortunadamente la
cúpula de hierro interceptó más de 90%
de los misiles pero desafortunadamente
uno
estos punteros sistema antimisiles han
cambiado la vida de mucha gente en el
sur de israel y han aliviado la presión
sobre el ejército además de convertirse
en una industria importante
contribuyendo a las crecientes
exportaciones de defensa del país pero
los críticos recuerdan que antes que
confiarse en la tecnología el gobierno
debería hacer más para solucionar la
raíz del conflicto con diplomacia
[Aplausos]